so
just I mean do you think that it is
helpful to pull all this stuff together
yes in one database yes uh to make it
much more easy for the voters to
understand yes
and why then well done I mean well no so
my question then is if you think it's
such a good idea why haven't you because
or your committee or other MPS done it
before this we've been trying to do this
for the last two years I mean every
minute that I've been every meeting on
the committee that I but since I've been
share there's one member in particular
Rita who has been endlessly banging on
the door of this and trying to get the
the ICT people here in Parliament to put
together a system that works so you can
look at everything you should be able to
see everything that relates to an MPS
um you know registration of interest and
everything that they have to that goes
to their constituency Association rather
than to them personally and so on all of
that my one the one floor I think in in
your version is that it doesn't have
anything from ministerial interests so
it looks as if
um back bench MPS
um are more involved in all of this than
ministers whereas in actual fact it may
be and that's partly because the
government is shockingly bad at
transparency they produce if you want to
look at all the ministerial interests
every year you have to look at 320
separate documents online and and we've
got we've had a similar problem about
that anyway
um so apologies that we've been slow
we've been trying to get the house to
make it its number one priority and it
is now and it was when we had a meeting
in November and I hope that by the
summer we will have a fully all singing
all dancing
um system but I want it to include the
ministerial stuff as well right I mean
because on the face of it you know MP is
the same to us but it's already
transparent but when you delve into it
it's not really as sound found with this
company mpm connect you know we couldn't
I didn't say about that when I saw the
one that you had x i IX Wireless but
this is a company I think donating
mainly to to labor MPS couldn't find the
staff or website I mean couldn't we
eventually found a secretary at the
registered office said she'd never heard
of the two named individuals so right
when you delve a bit deeper it is still
difficult to get to the kind of
information that the public may want yes
and there's an argument to say
um that um two things really first of
all the the registrar in the House of
Commons with whom you register you know
if you've been to an event or you've had
some outside earnings the registrar is
literally that just a registrar as
they're constructed and as their office
is constructed they simply register
things they don't have the power to
investigate the commissioner has the
power to investigate though that is
always predicated on MPS cooperating
with that process and there is an
argument to say
um that if you really want to make sure
that this is
um you know all singing all dancing and
all the transparencies out there that
then you need to give the registrar a
bit more power to be able to investigate
the other thing is
we could have a system where at the
moment what you do is
I've just had a book advance
I send an email to the registrar saying
that it's from such and such person I
received it on such and such today it's
so much time and so much money
and sometimes they'll come back to you
and say oh can you give you give us the
address and have you done this through
your agent or not
um but maybe we should actually have a
system where you do it all yourself
online so you're entirely responsible
for your own registration and then we're
seeing your declarations on screen now
you're quite happy with that yeah
completely I mean transparency is the
name of the game I I I I'm not ashamed
of anything that's on there well the
Seven Grand from Qatar well
um which um
get it no well I guess it's benefits or
when on a triple no no indeed and indeed
I've spoken about this the trip together
I went to Qatar the Qatari government
paid for it the the con the standards
committee which I share we're looking at
whether we should introduce a new rule
to say that foreign governments can't
pay for trips for
um for for MPS that that would might
queer the pitch with the relationship
with the United States of America as
well but yes so it was a trip to Qatar I
wanted to go because at the time they
were the only extract place from
Afghanistan and I had 135 constituents
or people related to my constituents who
were possibly going out throughout that
evacuation unit and I wanted to try and
help them and but if I'm honest I hated
the trip
um I think I wish I hadn't gone
um and in the end I think it's good for
MPS to have good relations with other
countries but maybe we should be paying
we the UK should be paying for it rather
than other countries right we've got a
couple of minutes left Sam do you want
to you might have to get this microphone
in yeah
is there a problem around disclosure and
transparency look the point is that MPS
can take money from companies right and
those companies can be quite opaque is
there an issue so two things take money
from companies that's that's a big term
so there's I I think your meaning
donations to constituent to constituency
parties and elections so that's not
money that goes into their own buckets
and I think it's important to
disaggregate these things out that's one
thing and of course I think everybody
needs to know where this money is really
coming from you may know in the Andrew
bridgen case recently this was really
quite a naughty problem about where the
money was actually coming from and we
had to delve into it and and of course
he will be suspended tonight for five
days from the house and for being
engaged in paid lobbying and the
um is it too easy for MPS to take
donations from companies and then for
the company itself to be really quite
murky quite indistinct very hard to
trace the source of the money and
actually because of that we don't really
have the transparency that we keep being
told that we do
um I haven't come across that until you
did this so it's again it's a Well Done
you I'm sorry I'm sounding really
patronizing I don't mean it that way
um I think transparency is in
everybody's interests and actually I go
back to the point I made earlier the
people you really want to know
um where the financial transactions are
are government ministers if they're
going off on jobs we may well get around
to that well but but that's the bit
that's missing at the moment and because
they're the people who actually make
decisions all I do is I shout at people
who make decisions
yeah but we've spent months doing this
so we'll we'll know
maybe and it may be that the house
authorities need to come to you to look
at what we can use from from what you've
done right that might just
shortcut the system so that we can do it
more effectively and there is a no sorry
and I'm conscious I didn't fully answer
Sam's question of course it should it
should be it shouldn't be opaque
the whole point of the register is that
it should be absolutely clear and when
anybody engages in their business as an
MP if they have a financial interest
they cannot Lobby on behalf of that
financial interest absolute rule it's
been there since 1695 in the orphans
bill right and this the changes that are
coming in March and uh you know paid
work for MPS as parliamentary advisors
and strategists and so forth go does but
does that go far enough you could
probably go further
um I think some of us would like it to
go further but this is where we got to
with um because in the end the motion
has to be tabled by the government
um I I think that
um undoubtedly there are some people in
the country who believe that no MP
should have any second job of any kind
whatsoever
um I think I'm not sure that that quite
works because everybody then goes apart
from a doctor or a dentist or a nurse or
maybe a farmer if they're in a rural
constituency oh and of course it's fine
to write speeches and um articles or
give speeches and articles and write
books and things like that
um so we found it really really
difficult to come up with a better
system than the for me the key issue is
if you have any kind of financial
interest outside Parliament
do you abuse it or do you abuse your
position as an MP to pursue that
commercial interest because that is a
conflict of interest for me that is the
single most important part of everything
that I've wanted to try and sort of
clean up about and but you only get to
know that if you have full transparency
are not you know murky cloudy
transparency full unopaque
opales no that's wrong I don't know what
word but just find it I mean should it
be down to us and salmon the tortoise
and so you know to do this it should be
down to you um
but what I mean this it could have been
done years ago
well
um I'm not sure I mean our register at
least you can go online and you can if
you type in Chris Bryant register of
financial interests it will all come up
and indeed I think um they work for you
has a version which keeps your previous
register as well online and there's an
argument for us for us doing that in the
house or so that it's all constantly
collated we've also changed the rule so
that from the first of March if you have
an outside interest you you can't that
that lasts as it were for 12 months
rather than six months at the moment so
we are tightening up the rules I'm aware
of any calls for more timely and where
Peter bottoman is here so um in fact we
could actually just talk now to thanks
very much indeed